hello and welcome to pi data global 2021
my name is natalie and i'm very happy to
be here and to be your host for this
session
i would like to now welcome um francesco
les lisig to our session and he will be
talking about darts for time series
forecasting
francesco is a data scientist at unit 8
with experience in ml ai projects in
various industries
such as finance pharma and energy
during his time at unit 8 he has also
had the opportunity to become one of the
main contributors to the dac's open
source library
and with that i will give the floor to
francesco thank you so much for joining
us today
all right hi everyone uh today we're
gonna be presenting darts me and julian
and uh let me jump right into the intro
so before we start presenting darts i
would actually briefly
like to say a few things about
forecasting in general so
why is forecasting important to
emphasize the universality of this class
of problems let me walk you through
three simple examples from different
industries so
for instance um
one
important question that a retail
corporation needs to answer is how much
of each product should they buy to make
sure the demands of the customers are
met
or similarly considering that energy
storage is still in its infancy an
energy company has to match the energy
demand
with its production as closely as
possible so they need to know what the
demand will look like but also have an
estimate of what various power plants
will be able to produce
and
this is not always clear think for solar
for example
finally an internet service provider
must have enough infrastructure in place
to support peak network usage new
resources cannot be installed in a
matter of seconds so again they need an
estimate of what the future is going to
look like and in this case
that is in terms of network traffic
and in all these areas we have plenty of
information about the past but we need
to know what the future is going to look
like in other words we want forecasts
and more concretely these problems can
be framed as time series forecasting
problems
so what is time series forecasting as
most of you probably already know a time
series is simply a list of values
indexed in chronological order where the
space between time indices is constant
and these values could represent
anything from world population per year
to
the hourly exchange rate between us
dollar and euro for example
uh the time series you see here actually
represents the daily energy production
of a hydroelectric hydroelectric plant
uh most of the time these types of data
extend up to the present moment and uh
to speculate about the trajectory of the
time series beyond the present
would be time series forecasting
so the solution to all the problems we
talked about before could in some form
be solved if we were able to perform
accurate time series forecasting and
just to be a bit more precise when
talking about a model that produces a
forecast we are referring to a function
that can take both the history of the
target variable itself as well as other
external data into account
but while many problems can easily be
framed as time series forecasting
problems not all of them are necessarily
solvable
so
the time series you want to forecast
must contain a real signal and it is
important that you know
which factors influence the signal
whether that's uh the target itself or
other uh factors that could influence it
if uh if you know that you have the
necessary variables then there's a good
chance that by using the right
forecasting model at least some of the
variants of your data can be predicted
into the future and people have been
working on these kinds of models for
decades now and there's a wide range of
possible approaches and uh luckily for
you we have developed a library that
integrates many of the best approaches
today into a unified ecosystem
so enter darts our python library for
easy manipulation and forecasting of
time series
and the focus of the library and in
particular of this presentation
is the forecasting part so the main
function of darts is to go from a
historical time series like the one you
saw before to a forecast of that
quantity into the future of course there
are countless variations of this problem
and multiple ways to approach it but
before we delve into all the different
ways you can use darts to tackle these
forecasting problems let me outline some
of the key principles that guided and
still do guide the way we developed art
so first
darts is built around a time series
class uh this is the currency of darts
you could say and it provides an
interface that is optimal optimized for
forecasting
second forecasting models and darts are
unified by a simple fit and predict
interface
as seen for example in second learn so
this means that pipelines built-in doors
are very modular and different
forecasting models can be easily
interchanged
third we think it's important to provide
both complex state-of-the-art models and
to sort of keep up with
the current research but at the same
time maintain solid statistical
approaches because we believe complex or
models are powerful but they should
always be used alongside reasonable
bass lines that are more simple
and lastly
we really want darts to be easy to use
two examples for this are
intuitive interfaces and reasonable
default parameters and you'll see more
about what this means later on
so before i wrap up this introduction i
want to give you a rough idea of all the
tools that darts has to offer because we
will not have time to talk about all of
them today and don't worry about reading
every single text box here i just want
to make the point that
while the heart of darts is definitely
the forecasting part it also comes with
all the other relevant functionality
required before and after forecasting
essentially our package offers an
end-to-end toolbox that goes from data
discovery to pre-processing to
forecasting and all the way to model
evaluation
so now i would like to give you an
overview of the
basic darts workflow
and let's explore the most fundamental
functionalities of the library using an
example so this time series represents
monthly mode production per cow in
pounds
and we want to create a model that takes
the training series which is shown in
black and produces a forecast for the
validation series in blue so the goal is
to produce a forecast that is as close
as possible to the
original
series
and in the following slides we will get
closer and closer to that goal as we
step through the different core
functionalities of darts
so first of all
the time series object it is the main
abstraction provided by darts and we can
easily instantiate one
for example from a csv file but there
are many other starting points we could
take
for example numpy arrays data frames and
so on
so this class provides many useful
methods for manipulating and visualizing
time series objects under the hood we're
using an x-ray data array object to
store the actual data
to create subsequences to fit and
validate our model on we can simply call
the split after method of the time
series class
one way to parameterize this function is
to provide the fraction of points we
want in the first subsequence
and now that we have a training sequence
we can use one of the many forecast one
of the many forecasting models dars has
to offer
one classic model is exponential
smoothing we can easily instantiate our
model fit it and create a forecast in
three simple lines of code
the predict function simply accepts the
number of time steps after the end of
the input series for which we're going
to create a forecast
and
by examining our forecast visually on
the right side we can see that we have a
model that although not perfect makes
use of the trend and seasonality of the
input sequence and extrapolates them
into the future
one of the main advantages of using
darts is that we offer a wide array of
different forecasting models to choose
from
so let's go ahead and try another one so
this model is coral
theta and like exponential smoothing it
sort of falls into the category of more
simple statistical forecasting models
and like before in three lines
of code we can
get a forecast that looks fairly decent
at least visually
what you might have noticed in both
models so far is that we didn't define
any settings or hyper parameters for the
models as mentioned earlier when
talking about the principles behind
darts we put a lot of emphasis on
assigning reasonable default parameters
to models so usually even without
specifying anything about a model when
creating it there's a good chance that
you can already obtain a decent result
out of the box
but of course we also provide the option
for more control to the user so in the
case of the theta model for instance we
can manually set the theta parameter
which will lead to a different model
behavior
and here we can manually set it to one
and again judging the forecast visually
i guess it looks pretty okay but
actually slightly worse than the default
model so we will stick to the previous
one
but of course we have to be a bit more
rigorous here when judging the quality
of predictions so how can we tell which
model is better and for this darts
provides
a wide range of different metrics which
given a forecast and the ground truth
give a scalar a scalar value that
indicates the quality of a forecast for
instance we can use the mape metric
which stands for mean absolute
percentage error which i guess should be
self-explanatory what it is
and or we can use the masc metric which
stands for
mean absolute scaled error so this is a
metric uh with many desirable properties
for time series forecasting specifically
uh and it actually requires an
additional parameter too so there's uh
some variation within these metrics and
how they're used
but let's just stick to map for now
so after computing
the score for both forecasts we can see
that theta is slightly better than
exponential smoothing which means that
so far this is our winner
we have to be
careful here though if we keep trying
out different models and parameters for
this setup we are going to overfit to
this specific train validation split but
luckily there is a better way in darts
to evaluate different models and
hyperparameters
so in a classical ml setting we could do
something like randomized cross
validation however in a time series
forecasting paradigm this is problematic
for several reasons so instead what we
should do is something called historical
forecasting
in essence we ask ourselves the question
of how a model would have performed if
it had been repeatedly used for
producing predictions in the past
actually darts is two functions
historical forecasts and back tests the
only difference here is that the former
returns the actual forecast while back
this goes one step further and produces
error metrics
directly but for now we'll just use the
historical forecast method so the way
it works is this so we start with a
subsequence at the start of our time
series as the initial training sequence
and predict the next few elements then
we send our training sequence by a
number of time steps and again produce a
prediction which lies a bit more in the
future than the previous one and we
basically repeat this until we reach the
end of the time series
so every forecasting model in darts has
this historical forecast method and as
you can see on the left side it is very
simple to use it and to produce
historical predictions as seen on the
right side
so
we can use this method to better
evaluate different models and
hyperparameter combinations
and
we want to use this functionality to try
out
many different combinations and also
different models but rather than doing
this manually
at least the hyper parameter part we can
use our grid search method to automate
this process
so to do this we simply define the
parameter space in which we want to
search over in a dictionary
and then we call the grid search
function the model class that we want to
optimize here we only pass the training
series to the grid search function to
avoid overfitting on the validation set
so
on the left you see the prediction we
obtained from the default data model
uh earlier and to the right you see the
performance obtained by the optimized
data model
which was returned by the grid search
function
so you can see we're able to further
improve the performance without looking
at the validation set so
this would uh be our final winner for
this very brief demonstration and this
all of course was a very simple and
idealized example in most real-world
situations it will not be this easy to
deal
uh with forecasts so you might need some
additional tools
uh to actually
get good results on more complex
problems so
uh now i would like to pass the mic to
julian to introduce some of these more
advanced functionalities of the darts
library
uh
stop sharing all right
thank you francesco
i hope everyone can hear me
um and see my screen
please scream
if that's not the case
all right so i want to
give an overview of some of the more
advanced features that we are
also proposing in darts
so
one of the most important things we are
trying to do here
is
providing
modern machine learning functionalities
for time series and what does that mean
so
on the one hand
we want
both support for classical machine
learning and deep learning models so you
know classical machine learning means
in darts you can plug in your favorite
you know psychic learn regressors for
instance and get forecast based on that
but also
we offer
a collection of state-of-the-art deep
learning models and we are always trying
to also follow the research and add more
models
but most of these models most of the
time they don't work really well they
are really not meant to be trained on
small data sets
they require large data sets and many
times there is to be trained on
so i think this is really key
uh here we have to depart a bit from the
classical notions of forecasting where
you know you would only have the setup
where you train one model on one time
series and then you use this one model
to forecast the future of this one time
series here with this sort of uh in this
sort of of of setup we would like train
big models on big data sets
and in darts each time series
object can also contain several
dimensions so it doesn't have to be just
you know a sequence of scalar values
over time
but it can really be a sequence of of
vector values over time
we also have support for
using past and future
data as input to the models
and i will also say a few words about
that later and finally
i'll also quickly show how
probabilistic forecasting is done in
darts because this is also something
very important
all right so first i want to demo a
little bit uh
what we call sometimes meta learning or
this ability to train one model on a big
data set of time series so here uh
actually for this example i i took 48
000 time series monthly time series from
a data set called the m4 data set
and
this time series have not much to do
with each other and i actually i don't
even know what they are so i just know
that there are monthly series
uh i showed here i plot uh four of them
that i selected more or less a friend on
and you can see that some of them have
um downward trend others have poor
trends some have you know strong
seasonality
uh others are like
looking more like random walks
um
but still we'll try to fit one model on
all of them so here um
i took this model called n beats which
was released
which was published one or two years ago
and is available in darts
and the way to train it on this whole
data set looks like this so basically
it's the same as for fitting on one
single series
um
except that here my my variable all
train series that you can see here
is uh is a sequence of uh 48 000 time
series actually it's um
in that case it's simply a list
because everything fits in memory but i
could also be a little bit more
sophisticated and have my own sequence
that would do for instance lazy loading
or something like this if the data set
is really too big
um
and uh then what i do is i ask this
model to predict to forecast the future
of the air train series which is the the
series of the air passengers traffic
um
and this series is not in the training
set so the model has never seen it
before
and
this is what i get
so
if it loads
all right
this is what i get so the forecast is
quite good actually it's maybe it's
probably not the best forecast ever that
you could get for this series but it's
very decent and i think the really
really cool thing here is that uh there
is sort of uh kind of zero shot
learning going on because again the the
this model has never been trained
especially on this series it just has
seen the beginning of the series like as
a prompt kind of
and
that means we can use this model in
inference mode only
without training and expect sometimes in
some cases maybe decent performance
right then this is nice because
inference is fast like even on i did
this on my laptop and it takes just a
few milliseconds to run
um other important thing is this uh
handling of past and future external
data and darts so here
the way we do it is basically we define
three notions in dart so first we have
the target series that are shown here in
green
and this is by definition this is what
we want to forecast
and then
we are talking also about covariate so
covariates are those the time series
that
contain contain maybe useful information
but we are not really interested in
forecasting them we just want to use
them as inputs for the models and here
we distinguish between past covariates
which are
um unknown into the future so for
instance things like measurements they
have to be measured typically
or future covariates which are known in
the future
uh so things like calendar events
you know holidays
weather forecasts or some actions that
you can take for instance
marketing campaigns or things like that
and the way it's handled in dart is
basically it's model dependent but
some models support uh past covariates
and or future covariates and we use
these keywords pass coverage and future
coverages so that means as a user
you always know whether you know your
model will consume historic data only or
historic and future data also so that
means that if you use future covariates
you know that at the prediction time you
will have also to provide the future
values for those time series
all right
um last thing i want to show is this
probabilistic forecasting this is also
super important and basically that
that's about like getting kind of
confidence intervals for for the
forecasts
so to kind of demo it here i built this
uh synthetic time series which is just a
sine wave
with
additive gaussian noise
to it and here the noise itself has the
very variable
intensity that you can see at the bottom
so
how can we go about
modeling and forecasting such a series
so first sort of naive option
is to simply repeat
the values that we have observed during
the last season but of course this is
too naive it doesn't really work very
well
because it simply repeats the values in
the in the history of the series and it
kind of overfits completely to the noise
so it just repeats the noise
um here we could also use you know sort
of a simpler arima model
uh which is uh you know in that case
doing a pretty good job at smoothing the
signal
and giving us point predictions but we
still have a problem because if you look
for instance here things are quite fine
uh
in this place we know that the you know
the noise level is quite low and the
forecast is quite good
but if you look here
the noise level is high and we would
somehow ideally want you know the model
to sort of convey this notion of
uncertainty
so here
we can do that in darts and here i show
an example with tcn model which is one
of the deep learning models and darts
and what i'm doing here is mainly two
things so
first when i created a model
i'm specifying a gaussian likelihood
which is the form of the likelihood that
will be fit by the model
in this case gaussian
and when i predict i ask for a certain
number of samples which i will explain
later it's used for doing uh monte carlo
something on the output
and by the way you can also see that
when i fit and i predict i also actually
specified some past chorios which are
actually the noise intensity so that
helps it's an external data i'm not
trying to forecast it but it helps the
model
um to
capture the fact that the variance has a
you know different frequency
so um how do probabilistic forecasts
work so for
uh nearly all the deep learning models
in darts it works the same way basically
um
they they predict the the parameters of
some distributions that you choose right
and that means that instead of um
fitting them with you know mean square
loss or something like this we are using
uh
negative log likelihoods for these
distributions or a variant of
this and
a time series object is really a 3d
object behind the scenes so basically
the first dimension is the time the
second dimension is the component so the
the different dimensions of the
in the case of multivariate time series
and the third dimension is um
stores these samples in the case of
probabilistic or stochastic series
so basically we can use that once we
have the you know the parameters of the
distributions as output of our models we
can sample trajectories
this gives us one time series object
a probabilistic time series and this
representation is really uh very generic
it doesn't rely on any you know sort of
parametric form or anything like that it
can really represent joint distributions
over
time and components of our time series
and
using these objects then we can do you
know
lots of things for instance like getting
the
marginal quantize and and getting
confidence intervals on some components
and i'm almost done uh so no worries
we'll be on time
all right um so
uh these are the list of likelihoods we
have currently in darts we have i think
16 of them
so you know i think this is quite
powerful tool because if you know that
your data for instance is continuous or
discrete or positive
or you know between zero and one or
maybe positive and summing to one or
something like this or if you know that
it's heavier tails than gaussian for
example in this case you can use maybe
the laplace or even koshi likelihoods
you know
so i think
it's very useful as sort of uh kind of
inductive prior to your model
and also we have
a sort of a bayesian component to it
because
you know it's very easy also to specify
prior values on the
for the parameters of those
distributions
all right so
this concludes the talk um
and to kind of uh wrap it up i just want
to say darts
tries to do two things so it tries to be
user friendly
and provide modern machine learning
functionalities for time series so yeah
please try it out
we have a pretty big backlog of things
we want to add
it's not limited to forecasting actually
so we're also planning to add some
anomaly detection in there for instance
and we welcome
you know any sort of feedback and
contributions
thanks a lot for your attention
uh there is a question can you define
static cover coverage
uh yeah that's a very good question uh
not at the moment but soon yes so that's
close to the top of our to-do list of
things we have so right now covariates
to be time series themselves
but we'll uh
we'll also add the possibility for that
so i think he also asked for a
definition
uh
so
so basically what we would mean with
static covariance is something that
would stay constant for a given time
series for instance um
you know as opposed to being a time
series itself let's say you have a set
of time series corresponding to
different product sales um then a static
cover it might be what
category of product you're talking about
so yeah for each for any given time
series it stays constant basically okay
um a question from christian is it
possible to provide your own estimate
estimators example
s as learn
um yes
yeah so there is a model in darts called
the regression model and it accepts any
psychic learn like regressor that obey
you know this fit predict signature and
works on tabular data so for answer is
yes
so unfortunately our time is just about
up thank you so much um francesco and
julianne for your talk and for being
part of pi data global 2021
yeah thanks for having us bye